what do you think is the overall meaning
or purpose of life what what do you
think we asked the or AMA sir can you
give me so many variations ones that
I've really enjoyed are to understand
the source code source Co of our reality
okay and then to maximize flourishing
maximize creativity consciousness
uh-huh-huh and then to take that source
code that we understand and create more
life from that initial source code and
let it evolve again to complexity so
complete the circle Wow yeah I like the
word destiny there's a lot of nuance to
that word and some say that you come
with a destiny you come with some sort
of gift or gem to unleash into the world
that you are born into I like that I
think there's something very deeply true
about that you have every one of us has
a unique potential to bring to the world
it could be that we have some sort of
free will in the sense of how much of
that destiny do we actually get to what
percentage of that we actually get to
and then it could be that maybe whether
you got to 90 percent of your destiny or
60 percent of your
to me that maybe that that was already
determined from the moment they were
born these are interesting questions and
that's why we asked them on the show
uh-huh yeah sure
big tree yes this has been such a
enlightening episode thank you thank you
thank you so much for coming on the show
and teaching us thank you asking me so
much questions that I have never think
about that's so hard you know hard that
the cause of interesting examination oh
what a funny quote we'll have to pull
that quote that's a good one so many
good questions harder than the college
entrance examination I love it I love it